all right it's time for my Deadpool to
spoiler talk that is what this is if you
haven't seen Deadpool - yeah gonna be
some spoilers in this video so now
you've been warned and as usual for my
spoiler talks this isn't a play-by-play
I'm not gonna tell you everything that
happens in the movie not gonna tell you
every reference that happens in the
movie that would be [ __ ] impossible
it's gonna tell you about some stuff
that stuck out in my mind that I
couldn't talk about in the spoiler free
review I'll talk about the spoiler the
top and the first big thing that happens
in this movie see this action sequence
is just it literally is a montage of
Deadpool killing people always fun but
then he gets home and Vanessa his
girlfriend gets killed which is funny
cuz after I saw the movie my friend was
like I love Deadpool won it was a
romance movies great is like yeah enjoy
Deadpool - I won't lie I felt like I was
kind of gut punched in the movie I was
like I didn't like that did that did
they do a thing in the mid credits scene
that possibly undoes all of that
depending on how they execute the next
movie I kind of want to talk about it
right now but talking about the
mid-credits scene at the beginning of
this video
feels a little strange so I feel like
well that sounds perfect to me just do
your video normal you will talk about
the mid-credits scene at the end of this
video I'll just fast-forward everybody
there right now bring it back here after
it's done like it never happened
I'll get some context trust me all right
there we go oh and he won't tell you
this but when Deadpool was burned near
the end his suit was burned totally look
like his x-force outfit that was pretty
cool
then he saves Vanessa he takes the cream
cheese spreader and kills the guy before
he actually shoots her felt like well
what's the point of the romance of
Deadpool one if in Deadpool two she's
just gonna die but now he's saved her
life so is she actually dead I asked
that because this mid-credits scene it's
just it's filled with comedy that can't
happen like he can't go back in time to
shoot Ryan Reynolds in the head because
he is played by Ryan Reynolds so
obviously that didn't happen so the mix
of comedy breaking the fourth wall for
comedy and time travel has been going
what it did is it real I assume it
Israel I assume he went back killed the
dude she didn't actually die so she can
actually be in Deadpool 3 now which then
makes you go what was the point of
Deadpool - did Deadpool - actually
happened since he kind of got on that
path because she died if she lived it is
kind of a paradox if it all happened
because it couldn't have happened then
again that paradox doesn't apply to the
fact that the bear that Cable has isn't
burned anymore so his family's flying
but he still came back in time if they
were going on the paradox thing the
cable would just disappear the events of
Deadpool - wouldn't have happened
time-travel stuff with the fourth wall
break and stuff just Benjy brain but I
think it's a brilliant way to end it
because if Morena Baccarin or pikarin
however you say her name is it
I've always been iffy on how you
pronounce her last name if Mourinho
wants to come back for Deadpool three
she can if she doesn't want to come back
for Deadpool three she doesn't have to
Deadpool can just be like yeah I saved
your life but there's a multiverse I
guess so I saved her but it wasn't in
this reality so here we are kind of a
great way to leave it off doesn't change
the fact that I felt like I was tasting
sour grapes throughout the movie because
she died at the beginning until she was
brought back at the end it also does
render those sentimental after life
moments kind of pointless although but
fixing a timeline is the purest of
motivations if we could fix a timeline
like any of us would it's the same
device you think I could hahaha maximum
effort I have to try yeah that doesn't
work by the way so Wally's off
experiencing disappointment let's go
back like before we went forward there
we go bring it back here after it's done
like it never happened look at some
context trust me whatever that was okay
so we'll talk about it later well long
story short when I watched this movie I
did not like the fact that she died I
wanted to have a kid and I feel like her
death essentially gets him on the path
of like I got to protect this other kid
from cable that's like really the main
thing in this movie there's this kid
who's going to kill this guy who did
cruel experiments on him after he kills
this dude he gotta gets a taste for
blood he ends up killing cable's wife
and kid and cable comes back in time
he's gonna kill him so we can alter the
future and Deadpool's like no the kid
isn't it's not set in stone he can
change
he just doesn't kill the guy he won't
actually get a taste for which he blows
himself up there is a scene in this
movie where he gets ripped literally in
half he's growing his body back which is
kind of a play off of the last movie
when he lost his arm and he had the
weird little baby arm now he has an
entire baby body from the waist down
because it's all growing back when he
blew himself up I was like was there a
weird baby body growing out his head I
don't know it didn't show it so maybe a
lot of time past 40s Colossus gets ahold
of him brings him back to the x-men
mansion he references the other x-men
he's like Ken Ken
studio just throw us a bone and give us
more x-men his back is to this room
where there's the x-man I saw James
McAvoy's Xavier I saw Beast I saw
Quicksilver there were a lot of them was
what my head was like wait wait who
all's there and then they closed the
door and he doesn't say I've got to go
back and take notes of all the x-men
that were there and that did crack me
out but one of the things in this movie
is like alright we need to get an
x-force together and the trailer plays
them up so much like this is almost a
precursor to the x-force movie and
they're all in the airplane you got
Terry Crews you have Bill skarsgård as
acid vomit man I said in my last video I
didn't know the names of these people
which is really funny in the comment
section someone was like have you ever
read a comic book it's kind of weird to
insinuate that if I've read a comic book
I would know their name I mean I'm just
there like and done yep still don't know
who they [ __ ] are are you about to
come at me with the semantics of comic
books versus graphic novels in the
comment section oh yeah but they jump
out of the plane in the greatest use of
thunderstruck I think I've ever heard
and they all just sequentially die
invisible guy turns out to be Brad Pitt
hits the power lines acid vomit man gets
sucked into a wood chipper throws up on
Peter he gets burnt and have like
everyone's dead I was like wow I was
kind of looking forward to the x-force
doing something it was funny as hell and
if I'm bringing up the comment section
of my Deadpool to review so it was like
this is just too crowded it's gonna be
an x-force movie and that's it I was
like well Domino lives I suppose that
was the point to show that even she
can't get massacred with the rest of the
x-force with her power which is luck but
after this action sequence in this big
armored vehicle something gets freed
from that prison they were all hanging
out in that I feel took a bit too much
time and that thing is the juggernaut
the juggernaut is in this movie which I
loved juggernaut the character in this
movie I did not love the juggernaut CGI
all the time sometimes the CGI looked
alright sometimes he's the one I was
talking about where I was like looks
like a couple console generations in the
past even when juggernaut fights
Colossus Deadpool looks at the camera
he's like big CGI fight coming don't
have been phrased any better it is a big
CGI fight quite frankly it's the least
interesting part of the whole thing even
his big CGI hairy man ass almost like
that is that is not a realistic looking
man asked I guess Matt Damon's in the
movie somewhere
I didn't say him which is funny cuz Matt
Damon
also in thor ragnarok Matt Damon's
hitting up the comic book movie comedies
I guys be sure I heard a john connor
reference directed at cable which I
thought was weird like Deadpool does
call cable John Connor right did I miss
hear that I'm welcome to the possibility
of miss hearing that because if Deadpool
did call cable John Connor the only
movie where that would makes sense with
a time-traveling bad guy is actually
also John Connor is that movie and that
movie is not referenceable ever at all I
must have misheard you way before the
end of the movie cable shoots at the kid
Deadpool has put on the collar that
nerfs his power so deadpool gets shot
and he's there dying but what cable does
he has one more time jump and he goes
back in time and then puts his hand on
Wade Wilson and puts that little coin
there so when he jumps in front of him
the coin takes the bullet the kid sees
people care for him he doesn't actually
kill the Dean or whatever cables wife
and kid are fine because the teddy bear
is not burned everyone's great it looks
like the Dean's gonna get away with it
but now dub hinder just runs him over
but dopinder has a taste for that [ __ ]
now maybe he's gonna be the one who
actually kills cables family oh I do
think this movie I had a whole thing a
whole monologue in my spoiler free
review that just I couldn't phrase right
it was late but I think I can perfectly
phrase it now is this movie is funny and
it always takes the joke it's one of
those see the joke take the joke kind of
movie and that's a good comedy but what
separates a good comedy from a great
comedy for me great comedy will take a
step back and let the drama marinate for
a little longer it'll make the call to
go now we're not gonna take this joke
we'll take the next one let the drama
settle for this moment that this movie
doesn't have sentimental moments now
that this movie doesn't have drama in
fact the scenes where Wade Wilson is
with Vanessa in the afterlife I like the
music I like the sentiment of that so
it's not devoid of those attempts I just
feel like I can think of about five
other moments where I'm like you should
have taken a step back on the comedy
just for those things just my opinion to
feel like I'm not in the majority for
that but the movie is still a good
comedy the mid-credits scenes I thought
were it was the best
negasonic teenage warhead and her I
believe her girlfriend also fixes cables
time-traveling device gives it to Wade
Wilson Deadpool can now stream through
time he goes back and he saves Peter
doesn't save anyone else he's goes back
he's like go home Peter
just go home yeah it doesn't matter go
home please Peters like yeah this has
been kind of a scary day and Peter goes
on it's just one scene you see these
they look like pajamas it pans up you're
like oh my god that's shitty Deadpool
from X
Wolverine's actual footage from x-men
origins Wolverine and this gun comes out
of nowhere and blows away shitty
Deadpool because actual Deadpool killed
shitty Deadpool he's like hey just
fixing the timeline don't scratch me did
you shoot the Deadpool a few more times
our shitty Deadpool which we know from
x-men origins Wolverine wouldn't kill
them makes me feel good then he saves
Vanessa he takes the cream cheese
spreader and kills the guy before he
actually shoots her felt like well
what's the point of the room
yeah you've already seen this stuff at
the beginning of the video when I fast
forwarded to the end of the video which
is about where we're at now so I'm just
gonna go ahead and fast forward this
part and there you are it also does
render those sentimental after life
moments kind of pointless although but
fixing a timeline is the purest of
motivations if we could fix a timeline
like any of us would it's the same
device you think I could ha ha ha
maximum effort I have to try a lot of
banter with some really cool characters
and I will say Suicide Squad is what
okay so I did buy this movie on blu-ray
and it took me a couple of rum and cokes
to get through sorry I've never seen a
human head detached from a body before
it took me a couple of rum and cokes to
get roots I will say it's probably a
better time
if you're drunk yeah now it's a party
look how young I look oh that is
unsettling other than the fact that I'm
actually really concerned now because
I'm afraid of disappearing because that
was my past self am I gonna get Marty
McFly in here no alright I think it's
time to I can't look at it I think it's
time to go
but chin up we go back to a bright and
better tomorrow where I never have to
hear about this [ __ ] again alright let's
see if that works a Suicide Squad is
definitely worth watching and definitely
worth buying on blu-ray [ __ ] [ __ ]
multiverse
well whatever had to try but in the end
I had a great time with Deadpool - I do
feel like it has a bit of a case of
sequel I dismay
just because Deadpool won was such a
great experience because it's such an
unexpected experience and a movie that I
never counted on getting gets a sequel
that's really good but just not as good
as the first movie and I feel like the
internet chatter right now is all about
Han Solo and the reviews for that so do
remember Deadpool 2 comes out this
weekend enjoy watching it it's a
Deadpool 2 have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more oh man
time travel [ __ ] I got to be the one to
go back and do all that other stuff
otherwise it didn't happen but it did
happen
so yeah click right here to say more
gotta go
[Music]